attention même regarder le regarder ce
qu'il y avait je voulais absolument la
faire avec vous on a on est à écrire je
lui ai donné à mal merci ça donne et
c'est la cabine à bluff ou pas dans
touche pas au poste oui oui j'ai déjà je
voulais absolument la faire avec
vaccarino le bruno en plus c'est un bon
bluffeur aux joues tout de suite à la
cabine à bord venait pour d'accord on va
regarder derrière ce rideau ce qu'il y a
on va dire aux téléspectateurs et aux
chroniqueurs ce qu'on voit derrière ce
rideau
d'accord ils vont dire qu'ils bluffent
de nous deux d'accord si c'est moi qui
bosse ou si c'est bruno vous jouez
également chez vous il peut avoir des
trucs fous les terriers de l'argent et
tout l'argent à la clé il ya très peu
d'attention je vais très très fort
allez-y ne dit pas je vais regarder le
dit parce que vous voyez et je vais dire
après moi ce que je vois ça va mal c'est
marrant pas mal c'est marrant oui j'ai
bien oui oui oui j'ai pensé oh oui mais
ça c'est un truc qu'on dit tout de suite
comme ça non bon alors ça sert à rien
qu'ils disent puisque moi je dirais que
ben moi je veux dire la vérité
non c'est moi oui puisque ben non c'est
ceux là vont dire
là haut oui moi je veux dire non et
c'est moi qui le dit c'est moi qui vais
dernièrement c'est toi il y a denis
brogniart sur un poteau mais vous me
dire si oui ou non mais c'était moi
qu'il vous avez vu vous d'affiner brakni
en train de cuisiner une charlotte aux
fraises ou chez paolo fresu à l'ananas
puisque c'est brogniart non attends non
non non réguliers alors alors unique et
cuisine qui critique et que je vois là
attention accroupi alors regarder des
bourbiers voulait
façon
surtout sur 12 possibles
c'est un lama à la maca pris le tramway
à bordeaux lac a pris le moins bon voilà
c'est ça alors moi je vais vous dire il
y à un courriel ou un peu plus longtemps
et aura la preuve sur le visage qui va
s'inscrire pour moi il ya un poney
déguisé en licorne à à l'est derrière
qui bluffe à votre appétit ne vous dit
que ce bluff une énorme tâche à rowling
n'a pas encore passé la journée en vie
en plaine où le patron sait que c'est
moi et c'est bruno qui bluffe encore et
vous le patron
attention dans les monarchies le
regarder ce qu'il y avait
on voulait vraiment
taylor
regardez discrètement discrètement alors
bébert c'est mon pépère c'est ivan qui
boit un expresso fait passer pour george
clooney serait bon qu'il est plus proche
de lui ressembler que moi en même temps
allez c'est bon t'as vu là alors il est
originaire sa fiche terrible qu'est ce
que j'ai vu ce qui est écrit par moi je
dis oui pour moi y'a ya chevallier
laspalès avec une plume dans le cul mais
non je suis dit qu'ils se mêlent avec
moi j'entends je le salue m'a appelé et
m'a dit qu'ils venaient à l'horizon des
plumes dans la dans le non match ol et
laspalès avec une plume de l'effet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]